Congressman Jim Jordan mark meadows
foxnews contributor Sarah Carter Sarah
let's start with your report let's stay
on the facts here I spoke to three
people two congressional members one
person in the DOJ they all confirmed at
different levels that a hundred percent
the dossier was used at least in part
one person said was significantly a part
of getting the FISA warrant what are you
reporting tonight I'm reporting the same
I have spoken to a number of sources one
senior law enforcement official and
another in the DOJ and the dossier was
absolutely used as part of the FBI's
ability to gain a warrant to basically
spy on members of the Trump campaign so
this was this was definitely used as
evidence it was part impartial to other
evidence I believe that they were trying
to collect but the dossier was
definitely used in what's concerning
here Shawn is the fact that we know
coming from the mouths of members senior
members of the FBI who testified both
Comey and McCabe that the only part of
the dossier that they were able to
confirm that was actually factual was
that Carter page had actually traveled
to Moscow everything else in the dossier
apparently they did not talk about that
they did not confirm it's
unsubstantiated or they found out to be
false so this is very alarming and I
think that there are a number of sources
that are alarmed about this particularly
people within law enforcement who are
concerned that they were using this
dossier to find a way to look into the
Trump campaign right let me go to
congressman meadows you're the chairman
of the freedom caucus Jim of course the
former chairman so I must I must go to
the Chairman the current chairman first
are you getting the same confirmation
that we are getting you know obviously
Shawn talking about what happens in a
confidential setting is not something
that members of Congress are allowed to
do I will say this there is a growing
body of members who believe that this
dossier was a significant factor as you
were mentioning something as a
significant
significant factor in terms of the FISA
warrant but I think that there's a
broader question here why would the FBI
use a Democrat paid for dossier to
actually surveil another campaign but
wait a minute isn't it worse than that
isn't this where fraud upon the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court I was
talking to Greg jerod earlier today and
a lawyer an officer of the court
violating the law by knowingly using
deceptive documents to deceive the court
and we got to remember fusion GPS never
verified the dossier ever well exactly
and so it's not only troubling there but
I think it's time and Jim Jordan are
here tonight to call on our leadership
to say that what we need to do is let
every member have access not only to
that FISA application but to all the
outstanding work that chairman Nunez has
put forth in terms of gathering
documents it's time that every member
has the access to those documents and so
we're calling on our leadership to make
that available and that would mean the
speaker that would mean Kevin McCarthy
Jim Jordan yes I mean marks exactly
right if members of Congress get to see
this information we think that the
course will grow even more and say now
it's time to declassify this make this
public so the American people can
understand once and for all
what exactly happened remember Shaun
it's today one-year anniversary from
when BuzzFeed first printed that entire
dossier that disproven salacious
unverified dossier as Jim Comey
testified and said it was one year ago
today that they printed it a year and a
half ago that it looks like they used it
to go to the FISA Court Jim the warrants
let's make that available for members
like the contents what do you see you
know a triple double quadruple hearsay
none of which is reliable or even
admissible in a court but if that's you
if a Hillary Clinton bought and paid for
Russian propaganda dossiers on is used
to obtain a FISA warrant then what
happens then there's three fundamental
questions did the FBI pay Christopher
Steele the author of the dossier did
they use that though in questions of the
Baker's I'm hearing from sources
either call me or McKay paid do you hear
the same I'm hearing I'm hearing both
stories shine and that's why we have to
verify this we're hearing there's a
possibility that they did pay I'm
hearing from other sources that they did
not pay and we need to clarify that and
and that's a very important question in
the question all right Jim go ahead back
to it what's the point number two Sara's
right that's why we want the documents
that's why we want the documents made
available to members of Congress we all
have the same clearance we're all
entitled to see this make it available
give us the information Devon noon is as
chairman as chairman Meadows is said has
done great work and getting these
documents now coming to Intel make these
available for all members of Congress to
see and then I think you'll see more
members say you know what we need to
make this available for the American
people so that they can see what
actually took place here and if all our
suspicions and all the evidence points
to one thing did that actually happen
that's sure what it looks like but let's
find out for certain all right Sarah
let's go back fusion GPS never verified
the dossier remember they tried to
withhold who paid for the dossier and
banking records associated with the
dossier they don't exactly been truthful
honest and helpful and this is what they
deal in no they haven't and actually it
wasn't until October when the Washington
Post first revealed that the DNC in the
Hillary Clinton campaign and paid
millions of dollars to Fuzion GPS to
basically go after this Trump Russia
collusion narrative and that's when they
hired Christopher Steele and that's when
Christopher Steele went back to some of
his old cohorts people that he had he
had made contact with when he was a
former spy in the FSB and this is why
these concerns have been raised I mean
the Russians could have very easily and
according to my sources in the
intelligence community known right away
that it was being paid for by the DNC
and the Clinton campaign they could have
used it for their own propaganda
purposes and it appears that they have
and now what we're seeing is what was
the what was the amount of the systemic
abuse this was their systemic abuse with
the FISA warrants is it just related to
the Hillary Clinton campaign or does
this go be it would render anything
they've got it admissible the media's
been trying to sell this New York Times
reporter Greg Jarrett made a good point
to me earlier today that that in fact
that it was the new
York Times reporting the Papadopoulos
mouthed off to some Australian diplomat
that he had heard that the Russians had
dirt on Hillary
that's not even admissible that's like
triple hearsay Welsh on that that's
exactly why we need to go ahead and be
transparent with this senator
Feinstein's started this yesterday when
she released this whole fusion GPS
testimony I say let's go ahead and
release it all to all the members if
there is nothing that has of national
security interests then let's release it
to the American people and let them be
the judge this there is no collusion
there's nothing to hide so let's get it
out the gym no you're right Sean in this
story the New York Times a week and a
half ago this was this was laughable
four unnamed sources said let me just I
don't need a guy in Russia tells a guy
in London who tells Papadopoulos who
tells an Australian diplomat who tells
the FBI yeah a twenty Kay a twenty
eight-year-old shooting his mouth off in
a bar now that's the reason they
launched the Russian it wasn't the
dossier that we've been talking about
for the last year coming this is like
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain that that is just a laughable
story we know what caused this it's the
stuff we've been talking I am hearing
and I'm just getting rumblings of this
that some of the details are that we are
beyond our imagination in terms of FISA
abuse Sarah Carter well I see Mark
Meadows as shaking his head at you
agreeing mark I am I'm agreeing I you
know some of the things that will be
coming out are so unbelievable that the
FBI and DOJ would actually allow it to
happen and I would also say there are
other agencies within so we're over the
target we've been right all along you're
over the target and let me just tell you
we're focusing in homing in on that
target okay now we need to know the
truth Sarah laughs work for you tonight
yes the American people deserve the
truth they need to know the truth they
need to be able to find resolution to
this so that the administration and our
nation can move forward and that they're
not stuck in this for another year and
the media's been wrong the entire time
Jim you're smiling you what last comment
we'll give up
because they're Sarah was great look
we'll let just let it let number see it
let members see it
I agree then then let's do because she
exactly I agree all right thank you all
this is scary actually in a lot of ways
we will follow this every step of the
way